[Music]
we're a marketing services company that
brings storytelling and Technology
together to Foster health wealth and
happiness in the world it's about
combining the physical world with
digital technology to either Drive Top
Line growth or improve the efficiency of
business operations
I enrolled in the digital transformation
program because I saw a growing number
of our clients taking ownership of
strategic Transformations within their
organization the courses and the content
of the program at Stanford lined up well
to the real world challenges that I'm
seeing every day this is the first time
I've enrolled in any type of remote
learning and I found a variety of
teaching styles and the combination of
course materials to be really effective
at keeping me engaged and really making
it feel you know similar to traditional
in-person learning
what motivates me is seeing the the
people around me and the clients that we
serve uh really grow and flourish
success more often than not translates
into happiness a sense of accomplishment
and a sense of fulfillment so I'm
looking forward to applying what I've
learned over the past year to both my
company and to the client organizations
that we have the Good Fortune to work
with
thank you
[Music]